l'invité principal de ce journal est
michel platini célèbre numéro 10
français aujourd'hui numéro 10 italiens
en effet vous êtes depuis trois mois à
la juventus michel platini vous semblez
y avoir très vite gagné une grande
popularité
une place solide à l'intérieur de cette
équipe prestigieuse
alors avant de vous interroger voyons un
reportage victor vraiment qui est notre
envoyé spécial pour antenne 2 en italie
en permanence et qui nous propose vous
propose la vision et si cela vous plaît
un portrait de platini l'italie ça vient
son singe entier sont gentils les gens
italie et puis julien ça va ça progrès
un ça va mais je crois que le service le
plus francophone d'italie et beaucoup de
monde qui parle français on se sent
vraiment pas du tout dépaysé on est bien
je m'y ennuie
en tout cas quand vous êtes sorti les
gens sont précipités pour demander des
autographes
ça y est vous êtes adopté excès vont
rire ou en adopter sont un peu collant
ils sont peu pratiques
ça change un peu du du
de la france football et c'est une
institution a une histoire un bonbon en
france on est footballeur on m'a comme
ça ici on est beaucoup plus considérer
tous considérés
m
et peut-être un peu trop peut-être un
peu trop puisque on n'arrête pas de
parler énormément d'argent qui joue sur
le sur le football donc c'est un
phénomène social il ya des milliers de
gens qui vivent du football c'est une
importance terrible comment ça va avec
les jours les autres joueurs de la
juventus
enfin la nouvelle tous maintenant ça va
très bien je pense que bon mais en tant
que footballeur on les connaît tous six
ans ils sont très très bon footballeur
prisonniers la coupe du monde peut doit
faire mieux et en plus ce sont des
dégâts qui sent qu'ils ont su rester
simple
ils sont très gentils très très
sympathique très brave comment ici il
faut voir dans quel genre de club a
atterri michel platini
il y a six champions du monde dans la
juventus c'est l'ossature de l'équipe
nationale qui a battu l'argentine le
brésil et l'allemagne en finale et qui a
donc remporté la coupe du monde
en tout cas il n'y a pas le moindre
soupçon de complexes chez platini qui
joue avec par laurent s'est dit pablito
un monstre d'opportunisme il ne faut
jamais laisser une seconde seul devant
les buts
dino zoff 42 the guardian but inamovible
capitaine de l'équipe nationale
championne du monde antonio cabrini le
playboy de la juventus le soussou des
tifosi du sexe féminin est un très bon
joueur claudio gêne-t-il et il a
complètement neutralisé
zico et maradona en espagne et puis il y
a roberto bettega qui était blessé mais
qui recommence à marquer de la tête il y
as been f boniek
le char d'assaut polonais le second
étranger de la juventus avec platini le
but de la juventus est de gagner la
coupe d'europe on subit déjà un qui sait
tout renier
tout le championnat la coupe d'europe
donc tout je crois qu'on a les moyens de
le faire monter tout perdre si c'est ça
qui est terrible
le public italien il est plus chaleureux
que le public français plus enthousiaste
oui il est déjà plus nombreux et
s'intéresse beaucoup plus au foot
en plus cette auto calcio qui fait vivre
des dizaines des centaines de milliers
de personnes des dizaines de militants
je ne sais pas et ça passionne à peu
toute l'italie dont tout le monde
s'intéresse au calcio donc s'intéresse
au footballeur et sont plus fanatiques
ils sont plus près nous platini une
passe intelligente à bettega qui marque
de la tête
bonniec qui passe à platini but c'est le
deuxième but de la juventus contre
cesena pour la deuxième journée du
championnat le mercredi précédent
platini avait marqué un but contre les
danois en coupe d'europe marqué que vous
aviez tendance à donner des indications
aux autres joueurs allaient diriger un
peu c'est un réflexe de capitaine de
l'équipe de france à ce que me demande
un peu les dirigeants de gym disait 2000
ans et je viens de 6,8 sur un an
c'est celui qui me demande de jouer
comme ça d'essayer de conseils tout le
monde moi au début je disais rien je me
faisais un peu reprendre de volée parce
qu'il fallait que je sois patron il
fallait que j'ai pris alors maintenant
j'essaye de diriger un peu mes
partenaires parce que j + 1 possibilité
que de voir le jeu alors on me le
demande je m'en prive pas
michel platini arrive un peu en retard à
l'entraînement mais enfin on lui
pardonnera s'il est vrai qu'il doit
devenir le cerveau de la juventus
lorsqu'il y aura un match international
enfin pour l'équipe de france
vous revenez vous jouez avec l'équipe de
france mais dans la mesure où je suis
c'est un ami cher qu'aujourd'hui
je vais forcément sélectionnés j'espère